[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24 à
la une ce soir silence électoral en
angola 14 millions d'électeurs sont
appelés aux urnes ce mercredi pour élire
de nouveaux députés et choisir un
président et vous allez voir qu'à la
veille du scrutin c'est la fraude qui
inquiète l'opposition se mobilise nous
serons avec notre envoyé spécial à
luanda dans ce journal nous irons dans
cette édition sillonner les routes du
niger plus particulièrement la caisse
qui mène vers le nigéria des routes
dégradées et dangereuse vous verrez
qu'elles sont désertes en raison de
l'insécurité au niger et au nigeria en
proie aux attaques de boko haram
reportage à suivre enfin nous parlerons
de la mangue d'égypte elle est la star
de la ville d'ismaïliya elle les
autorités égyptiennes ont décidé de lui
consacrer un festival le fruit a subi de
plein fouet la sécheresse et les
producteurs espèrent obtenir de nouveaux
investissements grâce à cet événement
14 millions d'électeurs sont invités à
se rendre aux urnes ce mercredi en
angola qu'ils devront choisir des
députés et un président à la veille du
scrutin c'est la crainte de la fraude
qui domine mais l'opposition et
certaines associations de la société
civile se mobilise et appelle à un
contrôle citoyen du processus électoral
les précisions à luanda de notre envoyé
spécial clément bono
pour l'opposition et une partie de la
société civile angolaise le risque de
fraude électorale est bien réelle pour
la première fois cette année le calcul
des résultats sera centralisée au niveau
de la commission nationale électorale la
ceni c'est à dire qu'il n'y aura aucune
compilation des résultats au niveau
municipal et provincial
autre sujet d'inquiétude le fichier
électoral plusieurs organisations de la
société civile ont dénoncé la présence
sur ce fichier de 2 millions d'électeurs
est décédé pour garantir un processus
plus transparent modèle une association
citoyenne angolaise a mis en place une
plateforme pour récolter et diffuser les
résultats de chaque bureau de vote en
temps réel dans notre base de données
sera alimenté par les personnes qui vont
aller de bureaux de vote en bureaux de
vote et elles seront nombreuses dans
tout le pays pour prendre des photos
j'espère m
du procès verbal de chaque bureau de
vote
et ces procès verbaux seront ensuite
compilées au niveau central et publiée
sur une plateforme qui sera disponible
dès que les premiers résultats
commenceront à arriver sur notre page
jco angola points
le principal parti d'opposition l'unita
a de son côté appelé les électeurs à
rester à proximité des bureaux de vote
après avoir glissé leur bulletin dans
l'urne une démarche critiquée par la
commission nationale électorale et qui
assure que toutes les conditions sont
réunies pour garantir la transparence du
scrutin je loge les lois régissant le
processus électoral en angola sont
suffisamment solides en termes de
garanties pour que le processus
électoral se déroule à l'abri de tels
soupçons
cela inclut l'existence de listes
d'émargement
ainsi que la présence de représentants
des différentes parties dans les bureaux
de vote qui sont en réalité des agents
de contrôle ou services les partis
politiques selon la cnl mille 300
observateurs nationaux et internationaux
seront déployés à travers le pays les
bureaux de vote seront ouverts de 7h à
17h heure locale
voilà clément bonnerot notre envoyé
spécial à luanda il suivra pour nous
cette élection et il sera aux côtés de
juliette dubois le soudan toujours
frappée par des pluies diluviennes le
bilan fait état d'au moins 83 morts
selon un rapport de l'onu environ 146
mille personnes ont été affectées depuis
le début de la saison des pluies à
travers le pays ce nombre ainsi que
celui des localités touchées aurait
doublé comparé à la même période l'année
dernière
je vous emmène à présent sur les routes
du niger elles sont de plus en plus
déserté en raison de l'insécurité parmi
les axes les plus dangereux celui à la
frontière avec le nigeria dans la ville
de zinder les commerçants traversée
régulièrement la frontière pour acheter
des produits moins chers au nigeria mais
le terrorisme qui sévit de part et
d'autre à tous paralysés reportage
d'harold girard
depuis plusieurs années et la montée de
l'insécurité les routes du niger se sont
vidés salifou saler l'eau habituellement
ces véhicules et guident ses clients
dans la région 2 un des reproches du
nigeria aujourd'hui ces sorties sont
bien plus rares qu'auparavant il n'y
avait pas cette insécurité ça ne serait
pas comme ça quand même mal en ce moment
ce ne sont que les projets humanitaires
avec sa tournée les transporteurs comme
moi le commerce en général
fatiha que grâce à ses projets sur cet
axe qui mène au nigeria le niger a
obtenu des accords de financement de la
banque africaine de développement
près de 140 millions d'euros
principalement pour bitumer la chaussée
sur 110 km l'état actuel de la route
multiplie les risques d' attaques ou de
braquage resté coincé dans un de ces
trophées du conducteur une cible facile
des deux côtés de la frontière
la voiture qui doit aller chercher les
produits au nigeria ne peut pas aller
chercher 10 tonnes à cause de la rue
j'ai obligé de transporter des tranches
de 2 tonnes si la route s'améliore je
vous le dis même l'insécurité
avant la multiplication des attaques
dans le nord du nigeria salifou faisait
réparer ses véhicules dans le pays un
gain de temps et d'argent de l'autre
côté de la frontière les pièces
automobiles sont plus disponibles et
moins cher qu'au niger
agen d'air comme dans tout le sud du
pays les garages dépendent eux aussi des
aléas sécuritaire dans la région
même les véhicules d'auto commande des
pièces les bandits les bras qu ils
arrachent qu'on allait faire des gens
leur argent il ya vraiment un problème
c'est pour ça que les gens disent
maintenant chercher des pièces
automobiles uniquement là où ils sont
ils les monte carlo dans le nord du
nigeria beaucoup à rome mais aussi
d'autres groupes armés ont provoqué la
fermeture de la frontière avec le niger
à plusieurs reprises
la côte d'ivoire a pour projet de
développer le tourisme mémoriel
précisément celui en lien avec la traite
négrière les esclaves traversé de
nombreuses zones avant d'embarquer pour
l'amérique les antilles et les caraïbes
en afrique de l'ouest les pays côtiers
ont tous une histoire liée à l'
esclavage nos confrères de la première
nathalie sarfati et nordine bensmaïl se
sont rendus dans un village ivoirien
marqué par cette histoire reportage
comme gagnant 2 et à une centaine de km
au nord d'abidjan ce petit village est
aujourd'hui un haut lieu de la mémoire
de la traite négrière
il a été répertorié grâce au travail de
l'historien aka kouamé aujourd'hui
accompagné du martinique et georges
raboteur
avoir à l'unesco qu' aucune zone côtière
n'était à la halqa de la traite
même là où on ne vend pas des hommes on
vend de vivre qui permettent à la traite
de se dérouler en 2017 les autorités
ivoiriennes ont érigé une stèle pour
rappeler que les captifs sont passés ici
alors après le banc parce que lorsqu'on
envoie ses escales il était attaché a
enchaîné et c'est ici qu'on est là pour
les rendent très pro pour les rendent
hommes il faut marcher quelques mètres
pour apercevoir la rivière baudot le
cours d'eau aurait des vertus mystiques
semblable à celle de l'arbre de l'oubli
à ouidah au bénin
parce qu'on pense que quand cela et se
souviennent plus de leurs conditions
antérieures et donc ça pour éviter et
souvent les révoltes nous connaissons
l'histoire mais au bout de ce b on sent
qu'ils à la porte du non retour qui est
toujours là produits non retour est un
peu partout revient toujours on sait que
la personne va quitter son pays pour
aller vers les amériques et puis que
c'est fini direction brembo à quelques
kilomètres de gand gagnante et la route
des esclaves passerait ici pour la
matérialiser une balise est à l'entrée
du village cela fait 28 ans que la côte
d'ivoire est engagée dans le projet de
l'unesco mais le processus est trop lent
pour les villageois qu'ils aimeraient
profiter de ce tourisme mémoriel
n'a pas les moyens pour pouvoir
lorsqu'on va ouvrir la route de
l'esclave on sera obligé de
d'ouvrir
cette route aurait vu passer des
dizaines de milliers d'esclaves
capturé au nord ils étaient rassemblés à
tiassalé avant de descendre le fleuve
bandama jusqu'à cap là où premier port
négrier de côte d'ivoire
à cet endroit les négriers faisait
traverser dans de petites pirogues les
captifs pour rejoindre une partie du
fleuve plus navigable
c'est une histoire triste c'est une
histoire d'enlèvement de ses racines etc
mais c'est extraordinaire parce que
regarder ce que nous sommes devenus ne
sont pas restés là à dire nous étions
des flammes au contraire on a profité de
ça on a réfléchi à ça pouvait faire de
mieux et je pense que c'est une c'est
une histoire c'est une belle histoire
l'émotion gagne le martiniquais venir
finir sa vie en côte d'ivoire en afrique
sur la terre de ses ancêtres trouve ici
tout son sens
connaissez-vous les manques d'ismaïliya
ceci ce n'est pas le cas vous l'aurez
peut-être bientôt dans votre assiette
les autorités égyptiennes mettent le
paquet pour les faire connaître et les
exporter un festival a été organisé en
l'honneur de ses membres dans l'espoir
de récolter de l'argent et investir
davantage pour la production récit de
caroline l'embolie
les organisateurs ont sorti les gros
moyens il met à l'honneur la mangue
produit phare du gouvernorat d'ismaïlia
en egypte des motos harley davidson
une fanfare ou encore un défilé à
rollers anoman gars je suis fan des
mangues j'adore et quand j'ai entendu
parler du festival je suis venu
directement
l'année dernière les agriculteurs ont
perdu 70% de leurs récoltes
ces dernières années la région
d'ismaïlia a connu des conditions
climatiques compliquées la récolte des
mangas étaient très faibles les prix
élevés mais on remercie dieu car cet
hiver le froid a joué un rôle clé et a
permis d'avoir une récolte importante et
qui doit faire face au changement
climatique
les agriculteurs n'ont pas le choix ils
doivent s'adapter le monarque
il y a des années le climat en egypte
était parfait pour la production des
membres
maintenance est en train de changer par
exemple on sort de l'hiver et on se
retrouve directement en été et
inversement ça c'est très mauvais pour
la récolte des mandats
mais avec plus de ventilation est un
savant dosage d'engrais et de pesticides
il parvient à atténuer quelque peu ces
changements d'autres exploiteurs ont
parié sur des variétés étrangère moins
sensibles selon
on a commencé à faire pousser des
variétés qui ne sont pas octobre plus
adaptées au climat actuel comme les
crimson l'ennemi ou l'igas mina elles
sont plus adaptés et peuvent supporter
des températures élevées et le froid
intense
mais pas question d'abandonner les
anciennes variétés avec leurs arbres
plus grands elles permettent de protéger
ces nouveaux arbres fruitiers plus trapu
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous l'info
continue sur france 24
[Musique]